I think I have an idea that could save
Ron
Andy film joke around I
I have ideas too
you were right to come get me my son
Ronnie always had a weakness for those
ladies oh wow is this Ron yep at the age
of five he's standing next to the first
Cherry ever built oh my God
there's a room full of Just Guns
why do you have so many guns
this is America isn't it
yes but I don't have to answer stupid
questions while standing on my own
property let's go
okay well that's definitely Ron's mom
Tammy
Ronnie what's going on Welcome to the
Battle Royale right here right now
operation soaring Falcon is in its final
stages
it's time to settle this
an old-fashioned Prairie drink off
jug it smells like Jack fuel that
Swanson family Mash liquor
made from the finest corn ever grown on
American soil it's only legal use is to
strip varnish off of speed boats if you
win he's all yours and if I win I bring
him back to the farm for good
wait what that wasn't the deal Port I'm
thirsty poor me one two then let me in
here I'm gonna
join you and if I win Ron stays here
with us Leslie no don't drink that we
use it to burn warts off of the mules
foreign
I made a mistake
I made a mistake
Liza
I'm not cheating on Paula you better not
be
oh great now I smell like midlife crisis
[Music]
oh gross Liz Paula you're cheating with
your wife what did you tell me about
this that's my fault I get off in the
sneaking around who knew right
parents oh no no no we will catch up
later I just came to get a clean sweater
[Music]
instead what do you do with the Pop-Tart
oh
[Music]
foreign
there will be a vegetarian option
too bad there's not an edible option
cream spinach will also be served
and for dessert violent illness
salmonella pie
the green apple two Trot
that's funny but okay and now a special
guest to make your morning announcement
this is called Novak there's gonna be
immediate suspension if anybody's
stalking at pornography oh she's really
busting my chops
hey guys this was a real kick don't tell
anybody that I you know went over my
wow I always thought announcements were
a way to impart Vital Information but I
guess what people like more are dumb
stupid dumb jokes okay everybody I'm
here thank you so much for covering I
really appreciate it you're the best
best the best at what
he is an odd little duck
[Music]
because it looks like there's a little
lighting issue there's a shadow you want
me to fix that yeah sure Helen why don't
you just take over the whole production
I
you really don't know what this is about
do you morning announcements were my
chance to be the cool guy to connect
with the students and you took them from
me oh real why would I ever do anything
to hurt you you pulled me up from the
gutter you're an amazing man I would
never take the announcements from you
well it's too late I'm awake now Helen
it's game Corner then you came in and
did in a way that I didn't know was
possible
I'm a fraud
you should do them oh
I should do them
I think that's what people want me
running around like a big dumb goof
I do that crap for my nephew and he's
five forever if you know what I mean
holy crap is that thing on oh beautiful
family photos
interesting he's got brown eyes and
she's got brown eyes but this old man
you know I think Eric got his blue eyes
from somebody on Danny's side of the
family huh yeah probably there's just
one little problem with your theory
there lady
it's garbage
yeah why because that man's fiance had
me dig through his genealogy to find out
if there was any chance that she could
have blue-eyed children and I still have
the scratch marks from where I told her
was impossible you're busted okay I am
admit it Danny is not Eric's dad Eric's
real dad is a big jerk and he wanted
nothing to do with us okay got it go
outside and tell him the truth right now
it's gonna Crush Eric it's his 16th
birthday and I don't have enough money
to get him a car or even get him a name
brand cake
spider hero okay don't care you need to
get out there and make it right Mama can
we please just wait till after the party
he's just so happy to have Danny here
I mean they do seem to be getting along
oh God
oh my God hey get off it kid pick on
someone your own side
okay let him hit me if you want to hit
me okay yes Hassel Lotto man expressed
their feelings through fighting or
dancing it's either the fist or the foot
except he's not a Castellano what stop
it you knew already
Eric
Danny is not your dad what
he's not
then why'd you tell me he was
because Danny is smart and he's educated
and I just wanted you to think that you
came from something good
oh great thanks for ruining my birthday
Mom oh if my friends asked for me just
tell him I'm up my room looking up how
to do drugs
thanks
I'm sorry I lied I had no idea that he
would reach out to you
yeah I'm out of here no
why did you have to be so perceptive
it's just my way Eric
I'm back honey I'm sorry
Have You Ever Wanted
the perfect girl to fit in your world
well don't make a wish because we're
already real low-rise jeans with a one
two zipper eyebrows thin bronzer thicker
whale tail peeking ready for the weekend
our eyes are all over you boy
[Music]
so you never have to meet them and get
asked why you left school
[Music]
and hoping for the best
we've got the kind of birth control that
goes in your arm and tell me again why
Tarantino's of Genius
you'll never want to wake up
[Music]
so we don't know that you're involved